don't bring anyone love into this Oh
questions came in via email no boy
conjoined twins who wipes with although
recent curiosity about how blind people
experience certain aspects of life I'm
reminded of the many taboo questions I
have regarding conjoined twins
I identify as an amateur scientist and
explain to my research most people wiped
with the same wipe dominant hand huh I'm
curious about wiping with conjoined
twins ah do they argue about who's going
to wipe or does one twin always wipe I
appreciate any input towards my research
it must warn you to try not to go too
deep down the conjoined twin Ravel I
think it's pretty dark thank you for all
the work and Congrats on the awesome
Netflix special Christina jeans up close
down Steven Wow well that's just I mean
I don't think we would not know but we
can put it out there obviously to the
universe well now we've opened up a
whole other can of biscuits I know now
we're in the conjoined twins questions
very I mean I have so many questions for
conjoined twins it I mean when it kind
of everything everything how do you do
everything how do you decide what you do
that day do they go they separate people
how does that even how do you know but
that's a great question God how do you
like someone the other person is there
for it obviously obviously so you're
always in an orgy like basically you
both have to be dating somebody let's
say theoretically and then you guys are
like everybody want to do it okay great
who what guy I mean I'm sorry or girl
meets the conjoined twins like I'm into
this I mean I don't mean it to sound
hateful but I mean really how it's too
hard just just logistically speaking
yeah not it you know just because you're
dating two different people basically
and they they have distinct
personalities so of course you're you're
always dating the sister and the
sister-in-law so how do you get out of
that how can you get over that brother
in the brother yeah it's a lot how do
you masturbate how do you how do
you also with the masturbate do you
realize that it could be like that like
I can join brother could be like I could
be like I'm I'm gonna jerk off he's got
a long shirt off like I want to go to
sleep I'm tired a busy of a day tomorrow
wait I'm horny no and then you have the
same body part fighting over I guess in
that case you let the brother do the
jerking and then you're just like why
just ignoring this yeah I mean the whole
I don't know I'm so set is that show the
show obviously isn't on anymore Britney
and Sally whatever it I don't know yeah
but they don't they don't answer the
important questions not any question
that anyone wants to know of course
they're their questions were like how do
you guys deal with feelings yeah I know
I wanted to hear about that when you're
about blow job how do you take a
yeah how do you date how do you how do
you wipe God if a police officer has to
handcuff someone and that person is
missing a hand what do they do how do
they handcuff them is from Dave that
seems like something that Ackley's off
there's definitely police officers
listen to the show
you must have run into that yeah I
imagine they would cuddle one hand then
you do the ankle thinks they can't run
away I guess the other hand maybe a hand
is too you know too dangerous to have
free so you got yeah you got a hank of
it to something but I want to I want to
know like if you're a cop and you've
ever been in that situation what do you
do you do you stick his hand down his
pants why would he do that just to be
like play with it down there we can't
have that out here a handcuffed his hand
to his dick and balls
that's silly Tom it's very silly but it
could happen all these great life
questions really great questions
important question about calm hugging my
mommy's I showed some friends the tip of
the come huggers one of my friends
raised an interesting question if
somebody come hugs you without you
knowing is that a crime how many tantric
rapers are out there Scotty oh and his
demonic wife creeped me out
thanks genes Jake Jake that really
and she is demonic the the smile is
horrendous on that the comb huggers
smile so weird they're so so weak and
the answer is yes of course that's
that's a form of sexual assault
if you come hug somebody without their
consent yeah to pull the sexual energy
our bodies so actually the longer we
make love the more energized we get yeah
right
such a weirdo yeah I want her and the
rub rub guy and the benadryl guy and
come in in the same room all of them
that's a fun movie yes baby like I
really feel like this is enough benadryl
and that do be like got a 10 or 12 10 or
12 the whole movie would be about
getting people to take more benadryl
okay 10 to 12 no it's not even even that
possible the Thai guy like coming to
many-to-many peel yes for 5 minutes babe
that's so many benadryl
[Music]